pack up your family and venture to a
secluded island where surely nothing bad
will happen
netflix's elves sure is a departure from
the 1989 classic santa must expose this
unholy force before the elves destroy
christmas
in this video we'll be taking a look at
elves a new danish television series
with a horror spin on santa's little
helpers but before we begin make my
christmas wish come true and like and
subscribe i'm always coming out with new
videos welcome to the quaint island
village of armensu denmark's number one
christmas getaway well not really this
place is about as empty as my 13th
birthday party here we meet the svane
family consisting of father mads
charlotte casper and josephine they want
to get away from the hustle and bustle
of the big city this holiday season and
have a more family-oriented christmas
experience this involves renting a cabin
in the woods on a secluded island
inhabited by some really friendly locals
but things aren't really what they seem
on arm and sue mads runs over something
and finds his car smeared in this blue
tar-like blood and the locals aren't too
keen on the family chopping down a
christmas tree
the best
by the way this is karen a francis
mcdormand impersonator josephine is our
protagonist all she wants for christmas
is to stop being treated like a child
frustrated she sneaks out in the middle
of the night to investigate this weird
fence surrounding the nearby forest and
there she meets kiko an adorable but
injured woodland elf and what do you do
when you're a young girl you bring the
creature back and hide it in the barn to
nurse it back to health little does
josephine know that this sets in motion
a terrible sequence of events the
vicious adult elves that live beyond the
fence want their child back and will
stop at nothing to get it furthermore
the townspeople have a cult-like
fascination with the creatures and
believe it is their responsibility to
protect them
here in episode 3 we learn how these
elves came to be approximately 10 to 15
years ago there was an accident at the
old lumber mill which caused chemicals
to leak into the ground this accident is
also what killed liv's parents liv is
the granddaughter of karen so in order
to keep people from exposing themselves
to these hazardous chemicals the
townspeople put up a fence or so that's
the excuse they give this fein family we
don't get much backstory into the origin
of these elves whether they were here
all along or it was this accident that
awoke them from their slumber regardless
for years the town and the creatures
have had an uneasy peace but the taking
of the baby elf has thrown everything
off balance when karen finds out that it
was josephine who took it she does what
any normal person would do and
chloroforms her to offer her as
sacrifice who's got chaos
that's how things have worked here for
decades the townspeople offer sacrifices
to appease the elves in episode one we
see how they use a cow as part of this
sacrifice but now it's going to be
josephine meanwhile casper and liv look
for a way to contact the mainland but
karen has already cut the cords on the
radio they'll later team up with mads
and charlotte and venture off into the
dangerous fenced-off territory to save
josephine joining them is mueller a
townsperson who has seen the error of
his ways following karen which just goes
to show you you should never follow it
karen in the eyes of liv and muller
karen has gone too far they confront her
but she's not going to change her mind
that is until kiko jumps from out of
nowhere buying them time to rescue
josephine while karen's body is eaten by
a group of adult elves the rest are able
to escape with one final showdown with
an adult elf who is later crushed by
their car they make it out of the fenced
area turn on the electric fence and make
it back to the ferry josephine's mom
says they didn't have enough time to go
back to the cabin and get their
christmas presents but that's okay the
present she got for josephine was a bit
too childish and she recognizes her
daughter is now a big girl completing
josephine's character arc liv also
decides to come along with the spains
she's always dreamed about visiting the
big city but her grandmother had told
her that wasn't possible her place was
here on the island looking after the
elves but then there's the question of
kiko who josephine bonded with over the
course of the series they left him
behind and muller tells josephine that
kiko will always be there in her heart
but in the show's final moments we see
that kiko has hidden underneath the car
as it heads towards the mainland
basically setting up a season 2 where
the elves will undoubtedly be in hot
pursuit but what did i think of elves
honestly with 6 22-minute episodes this
could have easily been a much tighter
hour-and-a-half movie and it wasn't
until i went over my notes that i
realized a lot really doesn't happen
over the span of these six episodes this
includes almost no emphasis on character
development arguably one of the most
important elements of a television
series the characters here are all
pretty flat with no interesting
backstories or character arcs and i'm
like give each member of this fane
family a flaw that they have to overcome
over the course of the season so that by
the time they do leave back for the
mainland at the end of episode six they
leave as better people i also wish we
got more lore as to the origins of the
elves and their connection with the
townsfolk you could do an entire episode
just on that there's this super weird
scene where the townspeople start this
cult-like chanting but it never goes
much further than that nor are these
dreamcatcher things that surround the
sacrificial pit explain now i thought
some of the elf kills were cool like in
the lumber mill but there are so few of
them to keep me entertained over the
course of six episodes and when you
combine that with characters you don't
really care about it's hard to get
invested and finally the show does try
to give some social commentary involving
climate change but it's just not really
fleshed out and the message ends up
getting muddled so this holiday season
i'd say elves can be shell thanks for
watching everyone make sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much